hello good morning welcome to Sky News
breakfast the UK is to evacuate British
diplomats from Sudan as soon as possible
the United States has already flown its
staff and their families out of the
country in an operation conducted by
Special Forces
British troops and military aircraft
have been moved to an overseas space to
prepare for a rescue mission however
other British Nationals have been told
that for now they should stay indoors
and shelter or one woman in cartoon for
a wedding sold Sky News that she was
terrified and needed urgent help to
escape I have been hiding under my bed
for the past
six hours
the area where I stay at the moment
has been shelled to shreds
I have heard nothing but explosions and
gunfire
and shelling
and screams
I
and my family members are terrified to a
point where we have gone numb
as a British national
I haven't heard anything from the
British Embassy
my only question is
if there is no plan to get me out
please tell me why
joining me now is our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes and
Deborah we're hearing more about the U.S
operations to get his staff and their
families out of the country just tell us
more about that and indeed how the
British operations going to get staff
out and also other British Nationals
like razan whom we've just heard from
yes so the U.S has said that they've
evacuated just under a hundred people
from Sudan that is all of the U.S
Nationals who work at the embassy and
other U.S staff they've left the local
Nationals in place uh to keep the
embassy open in terms of the actual
operation it's incredibly high risk this
is a very volatile situation on the
ground you've got two warring factions
still fighting there's no secure
Airfield to land and the U.S said that
they sent in a special operations team
using Chinook helicopters they flew from
a base in Djibouti which is a country
close to Sudan where the US has a large
military base and the helicopters
refueled in Ethiopia they then actually
they feel they refueled it in another
country in yeah in Ethiopia and then
they landed in Sudan they were only on
the ground for an hour as these
officials were put onto the helicopters
and then removed from the country the
helicopters were not fired upon that's
clearly something that the planners of
an operation like this would have to be
taking into consideration it's it was
very high risk they've managed to get
out but it really does underline the
huge challenge facing all countries that
have officials diplomats in Sudan at the
moment that they need to get out Saudi
Arabia and Jordan launched operations
yes the day before to to get their
people out and that included through the
port in the east of the country the red
Seaport again it's there's no freedom of
movement and so for ordinary citizens
like the person you've just heard from
it's incredibly difficult they are being
advised to stay in place we understand
that the UK does plan to to evacuate its
diplomats from Sudan as soon as feasible
but the government hasn't said how
that's going to happen they've said that
their the foreign office and the
ministry of Defense are working on a
number of different contingencies
um of course there's the possibility of
launching
um their own mission as the U.S have
done to get people out they could do it
in a coordinated way they could also ask
allies to help the uh the British
diplomats but for the British Nationals
that are in the country the advice
remains to stay in a place of shelter
the UK does say that its top priority is
to help those British Nationals but
those words aren't going to be huge
amount of comfort for people that are
unable to leave and at the moment don't
seem to have a viable evacuation option
being offered but of course that could
change because the situation remains
incredibly volatile and for the UK it's
clearly a high priority the Prime
Minister chaired his fourth Cobra
emergency meeting yesterday morning on
the crisis which really does underline
just how serious it's serious it's being
taken but also given the fact that
there's been no movement so far it would
seem just how difficult it is to be able
to conduct operations in Sudan at the
moment
Deborah thank you that's Deborah Haynes
there are security and defense editor
now this afternoon millions of us will
hear this sound
or this alert message will test the
government's new emergency system
designed to send warnings about
life-threatening situations like
flooding and wildfires
at 3 pm all 4G and 5G phones will
vibrate and send a sound alert for 10
seconds
you still receive the alerts even if
your phone is on silent
text message will also pop up letting
you know that it's a government tests
and that's in a real emergency you
should follow any instructions that you
see on your screen
you can swipe away at the alert message
or click ok to continue using your phone
as normal
and if you don't want the alert to come
through you can turn your phone off or
put it on airplane mode or disable the
alerts in your phone's settings
well there's there's never a perfect
time to to conduct a test but we have in
terms of time we have taken uh advice in
many other countries around the world
first of all they test their emergency
system secondly Sunday is a better day
because it's a quieter day to do it
we've chosen again in line with
International presidents do it in the
afternoon because that tends to be a bit
of a a quieter time so I will what I'd
say to people is
please just put up with the
inconvenience for 10 seconds because
it's a test of a system that in future
could save your life
now joined by Caroline Douglas he's the
executive manager for flood management
at the environment agencies good to have
you with us just tell us a little bit
more about why this alert is being
carried out today
uh well the alert is a really important
tool to be able to add to our toolbox
for flood warnings for example so today
is a chance to let people know what it
might sound like what would happen in
the case or if they should get it if
they need to do it in an emergency and
so today is really a test so let people
know this is what it sounds like this is
what you need to do if you hear it on
your phone and what are you expecting to
learn from this
I think the main thing is uh to help
people understand what it is so that it
doesn't come in a surprise as a surprise
when it does happen it will come as a
surprise I'm sure to some people today
but when it does happen in a real
emergency what we need people to do is
to pay attention to it and to follow the
advice that's issued on the phone so
this test is around really another way
of telling people this is what could
happen in an emergency and this is what
you need to do
and also just tell us what this could
mean in terms of preventing people from
dying in future when it comes to severe
emergency situations like this and then
you also have people who perhaps may not
have access to mobile phones in this way
the emergency alert system is really
only another tool in our toolbox so if
we take the situation of flood warnings
we have an existing flood warning system
that we use that we ask people to sign
up to we will still issue flood warning
or flood alerts flood warnings and
severe flood warnings through that
system as with other emergencies we'll
also use either the existing systems as
well but this system is really just
another mechanism for when there's
really a severe threat to life so when
we really think there is something
urgent that we need people to pay
attention to and we think that there
could be a real risk to people's lives
we want them to pay attention to it
we'll this we'll use this tool and add
it to the suite of things that we
already use such as the media social
media Etc and so this is just another
thing to add
Caroline Douglas he's executive manager
for flood management at the environment
agency thank you very much for your time
thank you
and let's just bring you some breaking
news that's just coming into US
regarding the situation in Sudan and the
latest is that France is carrying out
evacuation of diplomatic personnel and
uh citizens from Sudan so that's latest
then coming in from us this of course
follows the news that the U.S has
carried out its operations
um it's taken
um fewer than about 100
um of its um staff and their families
out of the country
um U.S term reporting earlier that they
managed to carry this out safely the
operation only took about an hour or so
they said on the ground in Sudan so the
latest country then to also be carrying
out evacuation of um their staff is
France which is currently carrying out
evacuation of diplomatic personnel and
citizens from Sudan
thousands of Runners would Ascend on
London today as the capital's
world-famous Marathon gets up and
running in its traditional Springtime
slot for the first time since the
pandemic
well let's go straight now to um Aisha
zahid who's at the finish line for us
now she's looking quiet now but we know
that things will be changing in the next
few hours then when people start
flooding in
yes that's right Vanessa very quiet now
but that will all change in a couple of
hours the last few bits and Bobs of
preparation are going on right now as
you say we're just by the Finish Line
it's 26.2 miles away where over 45 000
Runners will be taking their marks later
this morning it's the largest London
London Marathon so far now what can we
expect to see from the day well we'll
have those Elite races amongst the elite
men's race of course we're going to see
Thermo Farah running he has already
retired from the track he says it will
be his last marathon race ever before he
considers retirement so he says it could
be quite an emotional day for him and
then of course we're going to see tens
of thousands of runners in the mass
participation event they'll be starting
down at Greenwich Park ending here just
further down the mall from where we
stood and of course passing loads of
London landmarks on the way Trafalgar
Square Tower Bridge all raising money
for good causes it's expect did about 60
million pounds will be raised for
charity this year in the marathon of the
official charity partner of course it is
Great Ormond Street hospital now one
thing that might play against the
runners today this morning is the
weather it's expected to rain around
about now anytime soon really until 4
P.M this afternoon but I'm sure that
won't be dampening anyone's Spirits
later on this morning
I sure thank you very much indeed
our asbestos may have been banned for
more than 20 years but the carcinogenic
mineral is still the leading cause of
work-related deaths in the UK between
the 1930s and 1980s it was mixed into
cement used on roofs gutters and window
sills until lag or insulates boilers and
pipes from our political correspondents
Mario Aurora reports on the appalling
Legacy of asbestos he just said um
you've been exposed to us that's just
unfortunately it's incurable Rose has
been diagnosed with mesothelioma an
asbestos related cancer with a two
percent survival rate my first thought
was
gosh Too Young To Die
because they said it was incurable
and obviously I was scared as how to
explain this to my daughters my two
daughters
for Generations asbestos was commonly
used in buildings up to 1999. I did know
of asbestos but I didn't feel
threatened by it was threatening me
because I didn't even
know about much about it really
did you ever think it would be the kind
of illness that you could ever get or
someone that you could ever get
absolutely not never never crossed my
mind at all
although banned for over 20 years
asbestos is still causing a shocking
number of mortalities there are over 5
000 asbestos related deaths per year in
the UK and it's estimated that around
300 000 non-domestic buildings contain
some form of asbestos including schools
community centers and hospitals and up
to one million domestic premises
unions are calling on the government to
remove all asbestos in public buildings
to protect workers especially
construction workers who are the most
likely to be affected the government's
current policy is that specials is safe
if it's left in situent it's not
Disturbed but we would say asbestos will
always be disturbed especially in
buildings like schools where you've got
children running around that are falling
apart a lot of schools are at risk of
collapse currently it needs to be
removed we contacted the department of
work and pensions for comment but they
deferred us to the health and safety
executive which said that rushing to
remove asbestos from buildings would
pose more risk than managing it safely
but MPS want to see tougher action and
specific targets to rid the UK of this
deadly substance first of all I'd like a
register of all buildings all types of
buildings throughout the UK that has
Asbestos and then the second thing let's
set a timetable to get rid of this stuff
out of out of homes and out of
businesses and out of public buildings
across the whole of the country for
people like rose the growing cause for
change will be a welcome step in the
right direction
it's taken too many lives
in losing too many people
through this Mari Aurora Sky News
and let's see what the weather has in
store for us
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this will be quite worked for many today
but it will turn drier and colder with
extensive nighttime Frost developing
Ireland and Northern Ireland are mostly
fine now but Britain has plenty of
showers and some more General rain in
parts of the southeast
East Anglia and the southeast of England
will see further outbreaks of Fairly
prolonged and sometimes heavy rain this
morning bringing a risk of Thunder most
other parts can expect showers wintry or
Northern Hills
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
to the crisis in the SNP now and the
party has appointed a new Treasurer days
after the currents the arrests of Colin
Beatty who previously held the job he
was released without charge after being
questioned as part of the police
investigation into the S P's finances
but a deputy leader of the s p Keith
Brown joins me now from Glasgow uh
thanks for your time on Sky news this
morning let's start with the front page
then off the Scottish Sunday Mail this
morning which says that the police are
investigating SIM cards linked to burner
phones as part of that investigation
into the Pisces finances let's just be
frank about this this doesn't look good
does it or you may disagree with me what
do you make of it
well let's be Frank this is the subject
of an ongoing police inquiry police have
been very clear that people should not
be commenting or intervening in relation
to that inquiry and I for my part will
continue to do that as I've Done Right
the way through leave the police to get
on with their work and in the meantime
the SNP will get on with its work we
have as you said replaced the national
uh Treasurer and that was done yesterday
we have a governance review looking at
governance within the SNP and if you
perfectly Frank the bigger challenges
facing people in Scotland at the cost of
living crisis and to that end the new
first ministers announced a new raft of
measures which will help people and that
is far more important to people than
some of the issues which have been
raised in the media
but what's also going to be important to
people is the fact that day after day we
are seeing these damning headlines what
impression do you think that's leaving
public about the party
well I've considered the point of course
there are challenges and we're trying to
meet those challenges we are already the
most transparent party in Scotland you
will know the smp's membership figures
you won't know the labor parties
membership figures in Scotland nor
indeed the conservative parties figures
we are the most successful party in
Scotland have been for the best part of
two decades but we do have challenges
and I acknowledge that the point I'm
making is as you said the headlines I
can't control the headlines that's up to
the media but for the people I speak to
and that includes people within the SMP
their main concerns are things like the
latest mortgage increase the fact that
the UK economy now has two and a half
trillion pounds worth of debt and we've
seen a lot the largest drop in living
standards in living memory so these are
much more immediate concerns but of
course yes the SMP has to make sure it
takes measures to rebuild its trust with
both its members and the people of
Scotland now the S P's Auditors quit in
September when did you learn about this
well that was when the the media made
sure that was public I mean shortly
before that time but of course that was
a fairly uh common uh thread amongst
many businesses and especially some
third sector and voluntary organizations
where Auditors are withdrawn from this
area of work that's happened right
across the country if you ask other
third sector organizations they will say
the same thing as well and so work is
ongoing just now to make sure we do have
Auditors to make sure we comply with the
necessary requirements or for example
the Electoral Commission
I'm sorry can you just clarify when you
learned about this shortly before it
became public
which is when can you give us some dates
because it became public in September
six no no we were talking within the
last couple of months
so Nicholas sturgeon then knew about
this and didn't tell
um Hamza Yusuf then basically is that
what you said so so when this came out
in September what you're saying is that
Nicholas sturgeon didn't tell you um
straight away how did you find out
no of course that just made the point
that what happened was we had a change
of Auditors like many many other
Auditors across the UK the auditor is
employed by the SNP decided they were
going to cut back the activities they
were involved in and that was true of
many Auditors and for many organizations
Hamza Youssef was not on the party's NEC
which is where that would be discussed
and so and you'd have to ask Nicholas
sturgeon in terms of what she knew and
when but what's very important is that
the party complies with the requirements
it has whether the Electoral commission
or other reporting requirements and the
party will do that
so what we're getting from this is the
fact that Nicholas sturgeon didn't tell
her own Deputy about this
no I think I've just said to you that
this is reported through the NEC so the
national executive committee of the
party is where this would be yeah but
you're the deputy leader of the party
and you didn't know at the time this
will be for the third time this was a
fairly commonplace occurrence so this
wasn't a crisis that we didn't have
Auditors this was a change of Auditors
and it was a decision by the current
Auditors in common with many other
businesses and third sector
organizations across the UK to retract
their business so this was no crisis
that required to be reported in
headlines this was something that would
be dealt with by the National Treasure
was being dealt with by the national
Treasurer and that's what's going to
continue to happen the work will be
undertaken under the new National
Treasure sure McDonald to make sure we
have the Auditors in place
so if you did know then why didn't you
tell Hamza Yusuf because he says he only
discovered
this when he took up
a role
well I have tried to explain the SMP is
governed by its national executive
committee that is where these matters
will be discussed thumbs up prior to
becoming first Minister was not on the
national executive committee so
therefore wouldn't have known it for
that reason he does know now he's well
aware of this he's initiated a
governance and transparency review
within the party which will report in a
couple of months we will not have said
continue to build on our reputation as a
party which is more transparent than the
other parties in the in the uh UK and
indeed in Scotland and we'll look to
make a party further transparent so
that's the action that homes has taken
since becoming first Minister and of
course more importantly in this respect
party leader now you propose to the
parties NEC that they should hire a
fundraising manager and also publish
monthly accounts but this appears to
have been blocked by Nicholas sturgeon
why do you think that she rejected your
sensible suggestions
I don't know where you get the story
that was blocked by Nicola sturgeon I
and a number of other people worked in a
governance review which was then
submitted to the NEC which didn't pass
the NEC which was taken forward in a
different guys of course I do regret the
fact that the party didn't take on some
of those changes I think they would have
helped for the current position but I'm
very pleased to see that that work is
now being built upon by the what
commissioned by Hamza Yusuf that in
terms of the governance and transparency
at review it's also true to say of
course the SMP changed dramatically over
the course of the last 10 years from a
party with a membership of below 20 000
still bigger than the other parties in
Scotland it's a party with members of
over a hundred thousand and that
requires changes to happen right through
the structures of the SNP and that was
too slow and happening and I'm very
pleased to see that that has been taken
forward now under arms are Yousef
now the deputy first Minister Shona
Robertson told our very own Corner
Gillis and this week that a culture was
allowed to develop at SNP HQ who do you
think was to blame for this was Nicholas
sturgeon as first minister to blame for
this
but I think there's a number of factors
involved in that not least was of course
the fact that we're going through a
pandemic so we were conducting meetings
recently through Zoom very long meetings
with a very large NEC and that is not
conducive to a situation where you can
have everybody having to say asking the
questions and having those questions
answered I think we've improved
substantially since then and we have to
continue to improve but it is incumbent
upon everybody on the NEC to make sure
the party members and of course the
public have faith in the transparency
within the party they can ask questions
have those questions answered and for
example it's my view and it's not agreed
by the party as yet and it may not be
agreed but it's my view issued
proactively publish for example or
membership numbers on a quarterly basis
we have nothing to hide we are by far
and away the biggest most successful
party in Scotland I believe will
continue to be I believe the snp's best
days lie ahead of it but let's make sure
we are more transparent than any other
party and make sure that every time
members have questions that need to
asked the NEC has questions that need to
be asked every facility is afforded for
them to have that information brought
forward
so what does it say then about the
transparency of the SNP that you as
Deputy leader didn't know for months
that the policy didn't have an auditor
and this I think is the fourth time I've
tried to explain that if there had been
some kind of Crisis that required the
NEC to be informed and take action in
relation to this then of course that
would be the case but it was not that
background if you have I I for example
within government had responsibility for
veterans organizations many veterans
organizations had issues in terms of
unable to fundraise over the course of
the pandemic they couldn't do even
rattling of khans at that stage to raise
funds they had difficulty in contacting
their members because of the pandemic
many organizations intersector had
situations where the Auditors were
drawing back from some of this activity
if even the big four Auditors have done
that to some extent so this was not a
crisis that required an immediate
discussion and resolution by the ADC of
course it's become more serious as it's
become more difficult to find the
Auditors and that is why the NEC is now
aware of us so the s p the s p is taking
the proper action at the proper time and
it will ensure it has Auditors and time
to meet its reporting requirements
Deputy leader of this SMP Keith Brown
thank you for your time thank you
welcome back to Sky News breakfast now
with us this morning to review the
papers as Anthropologist Mariana hotter
an author and broadcaster Emma wolf to
go through all of the papers for us so
and there they are in the screen good
morning to both of you it's good to see
you back
um let's just pick up then Emma because
um in the last hour we started talking
about this story she's on the front page
of the Times newspaper this MI6 spy who
was sent to a jihadist camp who then
ended up killing his own child let's
just um elaborate more on this story
yeah it's a really alarming
investigation Vanessa front page of the
Sunday Times as you say this is about a
British spy who in his 20s was sent by
MI6 to a jihadist terrorist training
camp in waziristan
um there were extreme there was extreme
concern and warnings and awareness of
his vulnerability and he later went on
to kill his own child now he was vetted
for overseas work and cleared as an
intelligence agent despite being scored
as the most emotionally unstable that
could be scored on their sort of scoring
systems he was
um
reported he had reported himself as
being sexually abused as a child he had
had a mental breakdown as a young adult
and during previous work for MI5 he his
wife had been sent to a refuge for
domestic abuse victims
uh these come from leaked documents
um and the details of what he went
through in waziristan is really quite
appalling he was washing and burying
disfigured Taliban fighters he was
witnessing beheadings all sorts of
things this man later went on to kill
his own child he was charged with
uh murder
and the Really astonishing thing about
this Vanessa is that the court now says
it has lost all the documents relating
to this case and they can't explain why
the government have a 74-page document
on this on the murder of his child which
they are refusing to publish my goodness
I think this is not going to go away
anytime soon there'll be many more
questions
um following up and there'll be pressure
on the governments and indeed the courts
to reveal more details on this um
Marianne this afternoon of course at
three o'clock we're going to be hearing
that sound which um the government is
testing out but it's very interesting
actually isn't it because the front of
the Sunday Telegraph there has a message
for anyone who uses hearing aids
so this is a reminder a warning perhaps
for people who use Bluetooth enabled
hearing aids where um phone messages
would go direct to your hearing aid so
effectively straightened your ears as if
you're wearing um earbuds at 3pm this
alarm will go off it will sound about as
loud as the loudest ring on your your
mobile phone so if you're not expecting
it and you are using hearing aids it
could be very unpleasant
um the Royal Society for the prevention
of accidents have also put out warnings
saying please don't be halfway up a
ladder don't be threatened or alarmed
when you're driving maybe be careful if
you're using sharp or dangerous tools at
3pm and it might cause people to
um be to jump to have a shock to
scramble to to find their phone because
they're not familiar with the sound that
it's making
um
I mean fundamentally it has to be quite
alarming in order for it to work as as a
sound that people would register
recognize and do something about when
it's activated for real
um this is only a 10 second test of
course and in principle these alarms
should be used for or planning to be
used for extreme weather events
wildfires floods but not things like
terrorist attacks and there is the
question How likely in the UK is there
going to be an imminent threat posed by
weather for example or flooding that
can't be shared with a populace in other
ways that aren't quite so immediate we
don't really have the same kind of
weather that you might have in Australia
with wildfires or huge life-threatening
storms in the way that um in America
they can travel very rapidly over large
land masses we don't really have that we
do have flooding of course but maybe
that's that's kind of where this will be
used but maybe text messages could do
that job
and um and Emma let's just talk about
how things are changing then in the
workplace I'm looking at this um the
story here in the um in the times I mean
look I even I'm confused and mind
boggles you know would you send a
WhatsApp to Superior would you follow an
intern on tick tocks too many questions
what are we supposed to do according to
this article
well the old rules no longer apply
basically this is a slightly lighter
story and it made me chuckle um
basically everything has changed since
lockdown but also since the out and
everyone working from home and you know
your employer is basically being in your
home space all your in your life the
whole time but really since the Advent
of WhatsApp and Tick Tock and other
platforms the old rules no longer apply
and no one knows what they're doing
really
um is it okay to follow your Superior or
a junior member of staff on WhatsApp
what about emojis is it okay to post a
picture of yourself in a bikini if your
work colleagues are going to see that
what about pictures of your children
it's a real it's an absolute Minefield
and the thing is there are so many
people who are different ages in the
workplace you've got older people who
tend to be the the bosses the superiors
they have no clue about the new rules
they don't they're they're seen as very
kind of off with social media use you
know is it more seriously is it
harassment if you like a picture of a
junior member of Staff in in her bikini
on the beach is it sort of odd if you
post a picture of yourself oh my
goodness too many questions I I tell you
what just mute them mute everyone
thank you so much it's been lovely to
have both of you Mariana hotter and Emma
wool thank you very much indeed to both
of you for your time